hi everyone welcome to biology professor
today we're going to be talking about
immunoglobulin structure and function
immunoglobulin is another name or
antibody
so we've all heard of antibodies as
being really important components of the
immune system I have drawn an example of
what an immunoglobulin or antibody looks
like here you can see it's a pretty
complex molecule so I'm going to try to
simplify it basically it's made up of
four different chains that are connected
by disulfide bonds that are drawn here
in red a majority of the antibody is
fairly constant I've shaded it here in
blue it doesn't have that much
variability on the other hand these
parts on the ends of the two arms that
are shaded in green are highly variable
our bodies are capable of making over a
hundred million physically distinct
antibodies that can recognize this huge
array of foreign particles that are our
immune systems might have to fight and
these these ends are very very specific
to a certain entity that they recognize
so for example think of it as kind of
like a lock-and-key where you have a
very specific part of a foreign particle
being recognized by this arm so now
let's talk about the role of these
antibodies in any
first of all they are produced by cells
in the immune system called b-cells
and they are specifically made to
recognize antigens so antigens are the
name of the the big thing that's being
recognized
so here the entire thing I've drawn in
red is the antigen the specific part of
the antigen that is recognized by these
antibodies is called the epitope so in
the example that I've drawn the epitope
is this small square portion that fits
like like a lock-and-key where it's the
key and the antibody dose is the lock
when an antibody recognizes an antigen
then the immune system is able to mount
an immune response against it and that
is the very basic structure and function
of antibodies and our immune system